Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to
another episode of The Tim Ferriss Show.
This is your host, Tim Ferriss, obviously.
And my guest today, I'm very excited to have
this guest with us today, Dr. Christopher M.
Palmer. Dr. Christopher Palmer is a Harvard
psychiatrist and researcher working at the
interface of metabolism and mental health. And
he probably doesn't know this, but I have wanted
to have him on for probably six to 12 months
and have been looking for the right window
and the right context. We'll come back to that.
Dr. Palmer is the director of the Department of
Postgraduate and Continuing Education at McLean
Hospital and an assistant professor of psychiatry
at Harvard Medical School. For over 25 years,
he's held administrative, educational, research,
and clinical roles in psychiatry at Harvard.
He has been pioneering the use of the medical
ketogenic diet in the treatment of psychiatric
disorders, conducting research in this area,
treating patients, writing, and speaking
around the world on this topic. He has
developed the first comprehensive theory
of what causes mental illness, integrating
existing theories and research into one unifying
theory: the brain energy theory of mental illness.
You can learn more, a lot more, and read many
fascinating case studies in his new book,
Brain Energy, subtitle, A Revolutionary
Breakthrough in Understanding Mental Health
and Improving Treatment for Anxiety, Depression,
OCD, PTSD, and More. You can find him on Twitter
and Instagram @chrispalmermd, and you can find all
things Chris Palmer at chrispalmermd.com. Chris,
welcome to the show. It's so nice to see you.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: It's great to be here,
Tim. Thanks.
Tim Ferriss: And I
need to give credit where credit is due
to Dr. Dominic D'Agostino, who first put
your work on my radar. And within several
minutes of watching a closed-session video,
within which you spoke on stage with one of your
patients, I knew this podcast had to happen. And
that's in part because I think we will find a very
curious overlap, a Venn diagram of your clinical
work and exploration and research and some of
my own personal experiences. So in a sense,
this is a very selfish endeavor for me because
I am so eager to learn more about your work.
And why don't we begin right in the action with
a case study. Could you please tell the story?
And I do not know the full story at all. I
really just have a prompt in front of me.
And that is the story of a 70-year-old woman who
had chronic paranoid schizophrenia for 53 years.
Why don't we start there, if you wouldn't mind?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: I'm going to actually use
her real name because she gave me permission
to use her real name. In the book, I call her
Mildred, but her real name is Doris. And Doris
had a horrible childhood. She had a lot of PTSD,
depression, other things. And by the time she
turned 17, she was diagnosed with schizophrenia.
She had daily hallucinations and delusions.
Over the ensuing decades, she tried numerous
antipsychotics, mood stabilizers,
antidepressants, and other medicines.
None of them worked to stop her symptoms.
She slowly but surely gained massive amounts
of weight. And by the time she was 68, she
was miserable, hated herself, hated
her life. From the ages of 68 to 70,
she tried to kill herself at least six times
and was hospitalized for those suicide attempts.
And at the age of 70, she was referred to a weight
loss clinic at Duke University where they were
using the ketogenic diet as a weight-loss
method. And she decided to give it a try,
for whatever reason. And within two weeks,
not only did she begin losing weight, but she
spontaneously reported that her longstanding
auditory hallucinations were going away.
Within months, all of her symptoms of
schizophrenia were in full and complete remission.
Within six months, she was off all
psychiatric medications and remained
in full and complete remission. Doris
went on to live for another 15 years.
She lost 150 pounds, so the weight loss
thing was secured. But much more important,
she remained symptom-free from symptoms of
schizophrenia; she remained off psychiatric
medications; she remained out of psychiatric
hospitals. She never tried to kill herself again.
And when I last spoke with her, she
actually said she was happy to be alive.
She attributed her recovery primarily to God, that
she really felt that it was a miracle from God.
And she asked me to tell her story far and wide
to anyone who would listen, in the hopes that it
might help even one other human being spare the
suffering she endured for decades. Sadly, Doris
passed away this past January of COVID pneumonia.
Tim Ferriss: That's an incredible story. It's an
incredible story on a whole lot
of levels. And lest people say,
"That's an n of one. I find it fascinating. But
the plural of anecdote does not equal data," there
are not only many other case studies, and I'm
familiar with some of your clinical case studies,
but there seems to be an increasingly high
volume of literature studies and other
evidence to support some of the mechanisms
that you're exploring with your patients.
And before we get to exploring some of the
mechanisms, which I have quite a few questions
about, because I'm so personally interested —
and for those who don't know, I have had lifelong
challenges related to hereditary depression
and other psychiatric — I hesitate to call
them disorders, but it's probably the most
awkward but appropriate label at the moment.
Let's dive into some of your personal history.
And I think perhaps an easy way to do that is to
start with the dedication of your new book, Brain
Energy. And this dedication is to your mother,
and it reads: "My futile attempts to save you
from the ravages of mental illness lit a fire
in me that burns to this day. I'm sorry I didn't
figure this out in time to help you. May you
rest in peace." If you're open to it, would you
mind sharing the backstory on that dedication?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah. I haven't
really done this publicly yet, but
my mom actually is a woman who had two lives. And
the first part of her life, up until about age 42,
was that she wanted a simple middle-class
family life. She and my father wanted a big
family. They were Catholic. They wanted four
kids. They ended up with eight kids. And it's
a Catholic thing. And that's all she wanted.
My father was a pharmacist.
He started his own pharmacy.
And he needed help, so she helped him. She and
he both worked 12-hour days, six days a week,
to get that pharmacy started. She would
always take the youngest kid with her to
work. She was often breastfeeding one of
them. But that was the life she wanted.
When she was 42, some horrible stuff happened
in her family of origin with her siblings
and everyone, all beyond her control.
She had nothing to do with any of it.
But it put enormous stress and burden on her.
And she had what she called a nervous breakdown.
That's how it started. And I think it started
with what we would call depression. It quickly
led to depression with suicidal ideation and then
shortly thereafter led to psychotic symptoms.
She began to think that she was Mary Magdalene,
reincarnated. She thought the world was ending.
She thought this priest that she had gone to
for counseling was Jesus Christ reincarnated.
And it was the second coming of
Christ, and she was somehow involved.
She would get paranoid, and she
became convinced that my father
was actually the actual Devil incarnate.
And that led to them getting divorced.
And the divorce courts were not kind to
her at all. She lost everything. She lost
all of her savings. She got none of it.
She didn't get any partial ownership of
the business she had worked her ass off to help
start, and she lost custody of all eight kids.
I was, I think, about 13 when that
happened. And I knew she was going to die.
And so I went to live with her.
And it was not a good scene. It was not good
at all. We were actually homeless for a while.
So my first day of high school was from a homeless
shelter. And I could go on and on. But the fast
forward of her story is that she lived the
rest of her life with a psychotic disorder.
She never got better. Her life was decimated. She
was able to take care of herself, which was great.
She worked various part-time jobs and bought a
small home and paid for it with her own money.
And she inherited a chunk of money from
my grandfather, a hundred thousand dollars.
But she was extraordinarily frugal,
so that was enough for her to live on
for pretty much the rest of her life.
And she had obesity and diabetes and eventually
a massive heart attack and died of heart failure.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you for
being willing to share that.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: And it's hard to
say anything, of course. And I hesitate
to even follow that with anything. But
number one, I'm grateful that
you shared it because I think it
informs who you are. It informs the
work that you do in the world and
has helped to forge this drive and passion and
dedication that you have with your clients.
And I have to imagine, with the many case studies
and the many more certainly that have not been
discussed publicly, for a million different
reasons, that you have helped save a lot of people
from life sentences to psychotic disorders.
And my hope with this conversation —
it's not even really a hope. It is a hope,
but it's almost a certainty that people will
be listening who are either directly affected
personally or directly affected with family
members or somehow indirectly affected by what we
would consider psychiatric disorders or psychotic
disorders. It is incredibly, incredibly prevalent.
And this might be a clumsy segue, but I do think
it could be a helpful one, especially
for those who feel lost in a world of
infinite information and conflicting advice.
Let's begin with definitions. Could you explain
your position on — well, first defining what
the DSM-5 diagnostic categories are, what this
is as a tool, and then your current evaluation
or perspective on DSM-5 diagnostic categories.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: DSM-5 is kind of the bible
of psychiatry, and it's what all mental health
professionals have to use to make a diagnosis. If
you want to treat patients and get reimbursed by
insurance, you have to assign a diagnostic label.
If no label is assigned, you don't get paid.
If pharmaceutical companies want to develop pills
for psychiatric disorders, they have to abide by
these labels and study pills for specific labels.
And the assumption is that these labels are all
discrete, separate illnesses, and they define
a set of symptoms, but more importantly,
they define a prognosis and a life trajectory
sometimes. They also define treatments that can
work and treatment approaches and how long people
might need treatment. And in many of those ways,
the diagnostic labels are actually useful.
And I'm not here to challenge any of that.
I think understanding what symptoms people
are having and understanding what treatments
might be helpful to reduce those symptoms is
actually really invaluable. And that's great.
But the reality is that every diagnostic
label in DSM is a syndrome. And what that
means is that it's just a constellation of
signs and symptoms that we put together,
and no one knows what causes any of them. And the
real answer is that when researchers have looked
at all of the diagnostic categories, it turns
out that there are two major problems with DSM.
And the two major problems with DSM are
heterogeneity and comorbidity. And what that
means is — heterogeneity means that if you see two
people with OCD or with autism spectrum disorder,
they can have extraordinarily different symptoms
and look and function very differently from each
other. And it can seem like there's no way they
have the same brain disorder or brain illness or
whatever we want to call it. That's heterogeneity.
The comorbidity part is even more confusing.
Because it turns out, if you have one
psychiatric disorder and you're getting mental
health treatment, there is an overwhelming
probability that you have more than one.
And you can mix and match them however you'd like.
And this is really important because it implies
that maybe our diagnostic labels, number one,
are not valid constructs. And number two,
maybe our diagnostic labels are not as distinct
as we think they are. Because if I look at people
with eating disorders, and they're all more likely
to have depression and OCD, but I look at people
with schizophrenia, and they're all more likely to
have depression and OCD, and I look at people with
personality disorders, and they're more likely to
have depression and OCD, the boundaries between
these diagnostic labels really start to fall
apart. And you start to wonder what's going on.
Much more importantly, when we look at the
root causes, the root causes that we do
know about for mental disorders, it turns
out there is no single root cause for any
singular psychiatric diagnosis. And this goes
all the way down to the level of genetics.
Specific genes even do not confer risk. There
is no one gene that confers risk for only one
disorder like schizophrenia or bipolar or autism.
One gene confers risk for numerous different
disorders. So there might be one gene that
confers risk for schizophrenia and bipolar
and autism and epilepsy and other diagnoses.
And so, even if you look at a single root cause,
like something so concrete as a gene, they're
not distinct entities. And the reality is that
the National Institute of Health abandoned the
DSM-5 diagnoses about a decade ago, recognizing
these aren't valid constructs, and we're not
really getting anywhere, assuming they are.
Tim Ferriss: Man, but it's a bitch to get
insurance reimbursement if you don't have
the right codes to work with, I guess.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Absolutely.
Absolutely. So you've got to —
Tim Ferriss: Got to play the game,
I suppose. When you were talking about the no
one gene conferring singularly increased risk
for one isolated psychiatric disorder, I was
thinking, wow, I got a buy-one-get-one-free
with my card that I pulled from the deck.
Buy one, get four free. Ah, what luck.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: This begs all sorts of questions,
including what are, if any, the plausible
underlying mechanisms that could explain
these constellations of comorbidities.
And perhaps we could start with the
ketogenic diet and just how it landed on your
radar. And I understand the scope of your
research and work is far beyond the ketogenic
diet, but I think it may be a useful wedge
for working into some valuable terrain.
How did that first end up on your radar?
Was it because of patients like Doris, if
I'm remembering her name correctly, who were
by not necessarily happenstance, but outside
of your care, were sent to weight loss clinics
using the ketogenic diet, and you observed
these ancillary but very powerful benefits?
And how did your familiarity develop from there?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: My familiarity actually
began with my own story. I told you a little bit
about my mom and when I went to live with her.
Even before that happened, I had my own challenges
with mental illness. And after I went through
that hell with her and homelessness and
everything else, it only spiraled down.
And by the time that I was in my twenties, I
actually had gotten to a good place. I was not
clinically depressed anymore. I wasn't impaired.
I was actually getting through medical school.
I had finished medical school. Actually won
an award for being one of the top students.
And I was doing my psychiatry residency at
Harvard. And so, anybody looking from the
outside would say, "This guy's doing well enough.
He clearly is not impaired by a mental disorder."
But I had metabolic syndrome,
so blood pressure was up,
cholesterol and lipid levels were awful.
I had prediabetes. And year after year,
my doctor kept telling me, "Diet and exercise." I
was doing a super low-fat diet. I was exercising
regularly. It was not doing anything.
All the numbers were just getting worse.
And he finally kept pushing meds and was like,
"You're going to have to go on meds." And I'm
like, "Damn, dude, I'm in my twenties.
You're putting me on meds already? And
that means I'm going to have a heart attack by
the time I turn 45. That is not okay. And I am
not going to accept this as my final answer."
And so I had heard through the grapevine about
low-carb diets. At that point, it was the Atkins
diet. And I had heard that it was helping some
people reverse their diabetes or improve
their cholesterol levels and other things.
It went against everything I'd been
taught. But I decided to give it a shot,
really just as my hail Mary pass. And within three
months, my metabolic syndrome was completely gone.
Everything was better. But
the thing that I noticed
was I had dramatic improvement in
mood, energy, sleep, confidence.
I became a different person. A person I had never
been in my entire life, even during good times. I
had never felt that good. And so I, of course, am
recommending this to friends and family who want
to lose weight or shed a few pounds. And some
of them are reporting equal results. So within
a couple years, I start using it in patients with
treatment-resistant depression. And lo and behold,
it worked for at least some of them. It didn't
work for everyone, but it worked for some of them.
I think that pivotal moment that really changed
everything for me was actually in 2016 when I had
a longstanding patient, schizoaffective disorder,
which is cross between schizophrenia and bipolar.
And he asked for my help to lose weight.
He had tried 17 different medications.
None of them worked. He was tormented
by his illness in similar ways to Doris.
I start this diet. Within two weeks, he's
losing weight, and I start to notice this
antidepressant effect in him. I'm like, "Well,
that's interesting." Within six to eight weeks,
he too spontaneously — it didn't
happen right away for him. Took six
to eight weeks. But he spontaneously reports
hallucinations, delusions are going away.
That man went on to lose 160
pounds, has kept it off to this day,
and has had a new life. Has had the ability
to do things he had not been able to do.
So, to get back to your question,
those were the serendipitous things
that just happened in my life. I didn't
set out on a path to prove the ketogenic
diet is a thoughtful intervention. It was —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it snuck in the side door.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: It actually snuck in the
side door and smacked me in the face. I was like,
"What the hell is going on here? This
is impossible." And for people who know,
the keto diet as a fad, weight-loss diet or
whatever, it is a 100-year-old evidence-based
treatment for epilepsy. And that was
a really important clue to me because
we use epilepsy treatments in psychiatry all
the time. Medications like Depakote, Tegratal,
Lamictal, Topamax, Valium, Klonopin, Xanax;
all of those are anti-seizure treatments.
And we use them in tens if not hundreds of
millions of people worldwide all the time.
And so I quickly recognize, well wait,
if this diet actually stops seizures,
and we use anti-seizure treatments all the time,
maybe that's the reason it's working. And wow,
this is shocking because it's really working.
And then I learned about the decades of
neuroscience research that we have documenting
what exactly the ketogenic diet is doing in the
brain. Changes neurotransmitters, changes calcium
channel regulation. Changes gene expression,
actually. The gut microbiome is involved,
inflammation. It's doing all sorts of things.
And armed with all of that information,
my career took off. I started doing more
research, collaborating with researchers
around the world, and everything else.
Tim Ferriss: Is it fair — this term came up
in the video that I watched, and in fact,
the conference name, I think, had at least some
descriptor of this: metabolic psychiatry. Is that
a fair description of at least a component of
what you do? Or would you use a different label?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: I
think metabolic psychiatry
is definitely an emerging field. There
are lots of researchers, neuroscientists,
clinicians, philanthropists backing this
right now. The Baszucki Brain Research Fund,
funded by David and Jan Baszucki, founder Roblox.
They are really backing this with passion.
I think at the end of the day, the brain energy
theory is bigger than just psychiatry. The brain
energy theory is about metabolism, ultimately
mitochondria, and how it affects human health
and how that can have an impact on the brain.
But it's more than the brain. The brain is
part of the human body, and the human body
impacts the brain. And so, I'm actually more
interested in the big picture. If you climb the
mountain and look down, or if you see the entire
forest from the trees, you see the big picture.
We're really talking about a new way to understand
human health. And that includes mental health, but
it also easily segues into physical health. So my
only qualm with metabolic psychiatry is that it's
focused on psychiatry. And I am a psychiatrist.
I'm passionate about helping people with mental
disorders, make no mistake. I'm not looking to
start a weight-loss clinic for just any Joe or
Jane who want to lose weight. That's not really
my passion. But yeah, I am going to be helping
people lose weight and improve their physical
abilities and prevent cancer and prevent diabetes
or reverse diabetes. So it's more than psychiatry.
Tim Ferriss: The Cartesian sort of
mind/body duality doesn't actually pan
out very well when everything is connected
with blood vessels and so on and so forth.
So let's take a closer look at some of
the outcomes. And I'll share some of my
personal history as a way of making that segue.
I have experimented with the ketogenic diet since
'96 or '97, I would say. And initially
experimented with the ketogenic diet,
a cyclical ketogenic diet, with one
day of carbohydrate loading following a
glycogen-depletion workout, it's a bit of a long
story, for athletic purposes. I was using it to
lose body fat and improve my body composition
while maintaining some degree of muscular growth
and anabolism by spiking insulin once
a week with this carbohydrate loading.
And it worked spectacularly well. I was using
it for athletic performance. But much later now,
I've done a fair amount of fasting, quite a bit of
ketogenic dieting. And when people ask me for fat
loss, there are many options. There are actually
quite a few really good options. But the point I
make is: if you suffer from depression or
anxiety, personally I have found nothing
close to as dramatic as the ketogenic diet for
eliciting a significant change. And it's so
noticeable for me that if I'm using, say, an
Abbott Labs Precision Xtra device to measure
ketone concentrations and millimolars,
predictably, based on how I feel in terms of
not just mood, but mental acuity. So speed of
cognitive turnover. I know it's not technical
term, but just speed of computation, short term
memory. I can tell when my body clicks over past
say 0.7 millimolars. Predictably, I can guess
where I am between 0.7 and say 1.0 millimolars
based on mood and cognition and furthermore,
over the span of several days, and typically
I kickstart ketosis with a period of fasting, I
just find that the easiest for me personally, but
I recognize the sort of adherence challenges that
can pose for a lot of folks. I also seem to — and
this is leading to a question, don't worry.
I also notice that when I am in reasonably
established ketosis, because I think a lot of
people think they're in ketosis when they're
eating a ketogenic meal once a day and that we
can get to, but when I am measurably in ketosis,
my need for sleep also goes down dramatically. And
I would say I wake up whether I want to or not,
after six hours of sleep and I feel fully
refreshed. I don't experience the morning
grogginess that I typically do. The question
is what the hell is going on? So biochemically,
from a genetic on/off switch perspective, what
is happening in the body that contributes to
some of these experiences and effects?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: It's a brilliant
question and I don't think we have all the
answers because this is a relatively new field
and in terms of looking at the effects
of the ketogenic diet on mental states,
and certainly in terms of looking at
it in terms of people with exclusive or
primary mental disorders, researchers
have looked at it for other things.
So the first thing I'll say is you're actually,
everything you described is spot on with what
I see clinically in dozens of patients and
what I hear from patients around the world,
and it's one of the challenges, I want to point
this out, you are highlighting the decreased need
for sleep is one of the biggest risks of using
this intervention in people who have had a history
of psychosis. And the reason is because for you,
it sounds like it has not been a major problem.
I've definitely seen people who have gotten
hypomanic while, especially while they're keto,
adapting to the point that they're actually only
getting two hours of sleep a night and they can't
sleep more than that. And sometimes they recognize
"This may not be optimal for me." And other times
they just think, "Well, I'm got a lot of time
now to be productive and get all sorts of shit
done." So I mean, one guy actually was going for
20-mile runs starting at 3:00 a.m. in the morning,
and he complained that he couldn't maintain a
normal weight and he wondered why. And I'm like,
"Dude, you're like sleeping two hours a
night and you're running 20 miles every day,
what did you expect?" I don't think you —
Tim Ferriss: Some basic math
can explain this. Yeah, yeah.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yes, absolutely.
The effects on sleep are complicated because
some studies like in epilepsy patients,
for instance, have found that the ketogenic diet
actually dramatically improves sleep overall,
but a lot of those patients are sleeping too
much and often because they're on medications
that are extraordinarily sedating. And so those
studies come to the conclusion, ketogenic diet
improves sleep, it normalizes it, people wake
up feeling more refreshed, it's a great thing.
This issue of hypomania and mania is very
poorly understood. I'm one of the only
people in the planet who seems to recognize
it as hypomania and mania, but so we've got a
lot of work to do in terms of understanding it.
I'll give you an evolutionary speculation about
what I think is happening, widely speculative.
We don't have the research for this, but I've
seen this a lot. Not just with ketogenic diet,
but with anything that induces a kind of ketosis
and a fasting state or a fasting mimicking state.
So I've seen this in patients who fast for five,
seven days or whatever, and there are actually
some studies in Muslim patients during Ramadan,
especially patients who have bipolar disorder
during Ramadan, they start fasting, they're much,
much more likely to have sleep problems and they
are much, much more likely to have subsequent
mood episodes, but primarily hypomanic and
manic, but also depressive for some people.
So I think that we've got enough evidence, and I
certainly have enough anecdotal evidence to say
decreased sleep is a thing, it's a real thing,
it's observed, we've got some studies to document
it. Why would the body need less sleep or
why would the body get less sleep while in
a ketogenic state? My assumption is just going
with a common sense evolutionary perspective,
which is the body thinks it's actually starving,
it's drought, there's a drought or famine or
something. Something is going on. Food supply
is scarce. That's why you have high ketones.
And so the high ketones are actually activating
brain regions to get you number one, more energy,
more confidence, and more time, you don't need to
be sleeping right now, you've got to find food and
find it fast. And so it gives people more energy
to actually go out, seek, explore, hunt, whatever,
looking for food sources. Again, wild speculation,
but at least in my mind it kind of makes sense.
Tim Ferriss: From an evolutionary perspective, definitely it makes sense and does
the mood improvement reflect, in your opinion,
increased release of norepinephrine or something
along those lines? Or is it remedying via ketones,
this alternate fuel source which the brain and
the heart and some other tissues really love?
Is the presence of ketones, remedy and underlying
glucose metabolism disorder that is in part causal
with the conditions that end up getting
pulled from the DSM-5? How would you explain,
even if it's just a tentative hypothesis, the mood
elevation that people experience? Because it is so
noticeable, it is not subtle for me in the least.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah, no, and it's not
been — I will share my personal story too,
because I've been in and out of ketosis for
many years and I find the exact same thing. And
quite honestly, sometimes the sleep, the inability
to sleep or sleep inadequate amount of time is
the rate limiting factor for me. And I'm like,
I can't go with this little sleep for this long.
This is not going to turn out well for me if I
stay on this trajectory, I know enough. So there
are lots of people with lots of different opinions
and we know at least 40 different mechanisms
of action of the ketogenic diet, like I said,
neurotransmitters, all sorts of things, so how
exactly is it resulting in this improved mood?
There's going to be debate. I actually firmly
believe, based on this larger theory and kind
of connecting all of the dots, I actually
firmly believe that it really does come
down to mitochondria and some people
call it mitochondrial dysfunction.
There's another group of researchers that like
to call it suboptimal mitochondrial function.
Tim Ferriss: Wouldn't want
to upset those mitochondria.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Because that's different
than dysfunction. Yeah, whatever. What it means,
at the end of the day, and we may get to this,
mitochondria are actually much, much more than
just powerhouses. But powerhouse function is
a critically important function and we have
evidence from numerous data sources, from blood
work, from lumbar punctures, from autopsy studies
to all of the neuro imaging studies that
we're doing, functional mri, PET scans,
SPECT scans, all of these studies, all of
them converge on mitochondria and functions
of mitochondria. And what all of these studies
suggest is that people with mental disorders
across the board tend to have regions of the
brain, so it's not the entire body, metabolism is
cell specific and tissue specific. So you can have
one cell that's actually ready to die because it's
metabolically failing and you can have another
brand new healthy cell that's actually thriving
in the same human body. So it's important to keep
that in mind. But what all of this research says
is that some brain regions and some people are
metabolically compromised, their brain tissue is
not getting enough energy and it also has higher
levels of reactive oxygen species, which can
produce inflammation and all sorts of problems.
But we know this, and again, tons of evidence
and different lines of evidence all pointing
in the same direction. Even genetic studies,
when you look at, well, what is this gene
doing and what's happening in the brains of
people with these genetic defects? You time and
again, see mitochondrial or metabolic impairment
or dysfunction and what I think the ketogenic
diet is doing is, it is, so I imagine a cell
that's only running on, it's a six-cylinder
engine and it's only running on three cylinders
and you give it ketones and ketones are rocket
fuel for this engine, and all of a sudden all six
cylinders come online and that cell is firing.
And for most people that's a good thing and it
gives people energy and everything else if that
metabolically compromised cell actually is in
great disrepair, if it is really miserably
kind of maintained and in great disrepair,
giving it all this rocket fuel all at
once can actually be really dangerous
and can result in a whole host of other symptoms.
Tim Ferriss: So could you elaborate on what a
dangerous case would look like? Because
presumably we're not talking about, and
please correct me if we're wrong, ketoacidosis,
right? In the case of say, type one diabetic who
has comorbidities and they have high ketones and
high glucose, dangerous situation. In what way or
in what fashion would this manifest as dangerous?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: One of the consequences of
metabolic dysfunction of a cell, one of the
big themes, there are several consequences,
I kind of break them into five buckets depending
on where and when. There are two primary ones
for an adult, say, who is just going, who's
developing new onset symptoms. And the shocking
thing is that they're polar opposites. So the
cell can either become underactive, which means
it's failing to work because it doesn't have
enough energy and that is, kind of make sense,
common sense, really easy to understand. But
the other consequence of metabolic dysfunction
is actually that cell can become what's called
hyperexcitable. It can actually become overactive.
And some easy examples of overactive or excitable
cells are a muscle spasm or a heart arrhythmia
or somebody with chronic pain who's experiencing
pain because their pain nerve is hyperexcitable,
it's firing when it really shouldn't be firing
or it's not stopping when it should stop.
And so metabolically compromised cells are
prone to this excitability. And the challenge
with ketones for some people is that you rush
in this ultra clean kind of high octane fuel
and the cell becomes hyperexcitable. And the way
that translates in terms of brain function is it
for somebody who's got a hyperexcitable
or a metabolically compromised anxiety
pathway or anxiety system, they could have a
panic attack or feel more anxious early on,
but for other people it can result in
psychosis, it can result in OCD symptoms,
it can result in all sorts of things. Agitation,
the extreme case of hyperexcitability in
the brain, is actually a seizure.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. The more you know,
folks, be careful out there. So mitochondria,
just to underscore mitochondria for a moment.
So the powerhouse of the cell, I mean the origin
story of mitochondria, we can leave aside,
I mean it's fascinating just to look into how
we ended up with mitochondria in our bodies, but
for the purposes of this conversation, the
powerhouses of the cell, I think it's what
oxidative phosphorylation they generate.
The vast majority are all of ATP, adenosine
triphosphate. So just let's just consider that
for our purposes and feel free to pick this apart,
but the basic energy of the body for most people,
most of the time there are a bunch of exceptions.
The reason mitochondrial function and dysfunction
is of great interest to me personally is not
just because of the depression, but a pet
theory/hypothesis that I developed after a
severe case of Lyme disease about eight to 10
years ago, I don't remember the exact timing.
I grew up on Eastern Long Island. Everybody
gets Lyme disease, almost everybody. My mom
also has the alpha-galactose allergy inflicted
by an infection from the lone star tick. So she
can have anaphylactic shock if she consumes
any mammalian protein, including gelatin,
which is in everything. So I grew up surrounded by
ticks and tick-borne disease and I developed very
severe Lyme symptoms, it was confirmed through
a number of different tests as a Lyme infection,
there are other co-infections, but let's focus
on Lyme for the minute. And the first thing
that this lab told me was, number one, you're
aware you've already had Lyme, are you not? And
they highlighted the fact that I had long term
antibodies, which raised questions for me about
whether my depressive episodes which started
around adolescence were in fact as simple,
I mean, that's probably not the right word,
as a hereditary genetic predisposition,
which there appears to be a component of
that, at least based on my genome sequencing.
Or if in addition to that, maybe a catalyst or
accelerant was this first infection with Lyme
disease. And the reason that is the second
time I had Lyme disease and the symptoms,
I made a very significant mistake and that was,
I looked for the bullseye rash. The bullseye
rash didn't appear, and therefore I didn't start
any type of antibiotic treatment. And it turned
out — this is going somewhere, don't worry, it's
a little long winded, but it'll go somewhere, that
even without the dermatological symptoms,
many people can be dermatologically,
asymptomatic and still develop Lyme disease,
which is exactly what happened to me. And the
only reason I went in to get tested is my
speech started to slur. I was forgetting
close friends' names, common words.
It was taking me five to 10 minutes
to get out of bed in the morning because my
joints were in so much pain from inflammation.
And I went through all of the standards of care.
I did the antibiotics, which had some effect,
but I was in this energetic no man's land. I was
incredibly fatigued all the time. I felt as a
result, these two things are often correlated for
me, depressed, what I would describe as depressed.
And I continued to have what felt like dementia on
some level for probably six to nine months until
I decided, and I can't remember what catalyzed
this, I don't think it was the Lyme, but I did
a week-long extended fast, and by two-and-a-half
days in and I was measuring my ketone levels,
which I think is actually really helpful if
people are trying to get a grasp on these things.
All of those symptoms literally vanished
by the time I got to 1.2, 1.3 millimolars
and not only did the symptoms evaporate, but
I continued to fast and then I continued on a
sub-caloric ketogenic diet for a period of time
afterwards. And that was an effect. And again,
I'm not a doctor, I don't play one on the
internet, so I'm not giving medical advice.
But this approach with Lyme and ketogenic diet
has now been replicated across probably half a
dozen of my friends, I should say this is true
Lyme disease and not someone who is dissatisfied
with life and depressed and diagnosis shopping
for Lyme disease, looking for an external cause,
which is a different story. But in this case, once
I saw the remission of symptoms and then I got off
of the ketogenic diet with the well-founded fear
that I would revert back to my previous state,
I did not revert to my previous state. So that's
probably explaining that maybe beyond the grasp
or beyond the scope of this conversation.
But what that raised for me as a question was,
are the symptoms of Lyme disease caused by some
type of impairment of mitochondrial function or
glucose metabolism? It just seemed like a
very fair question to ask and I know this
isn't an interview about Lyme disease, but what
should we know about mitochondria if someone is
not familiar with mitochondria, or maybe
they just have the basics like I laid out,
what do you find interesting about mitochondria,
perhaps aspects of mitochondria that would
be helpful for this conversation?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: So I'll —
Tim Ferriss: Sorry for the TED
talk. Thanks for listening.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: No, no, no
worries. It's a perfect segue into this. So
the real answer is that mitochondria connect
all of the dots of every factor known to
play a role in mental illness, whether it's
neurotransmitters, stress, trauma, hormones,
all of them, and I can come back to them if you
want, but let me follow up on your story. So you
had an infection, high levels of inflammation,
those high levels of inflammation are good.
They're good for your body because
your body is being assaulted by
this bacteria, these bacteria, and it's going to
kill you if your body doesn't mount a defense.
So the inflammation that you were
experiencing was good and healthy,
but yes, it made you feel like shit and it
impaired your brain function. We have direct
evidence that inflammation and inflammatory
cytokines and specific ones actually impair
mitochondrial function and or change mitochondrial
gene expression. So we know that that's happening.
For the most part, that might be a normal
adaptive response because again, your body's
mounting a defense for its survival. And so it's
allocating resources to fighting off this bacteria
and that means resources need to
come away from somewhere else.
Some cells are going to suffer as a result of the
need to fight off this kind of life threatening
thing. And we have direct evidence that some brain
cells have a reduction in mitochondrial function.
I think for people who are already on the
edge, people who've had depression in the past,
maybe people who have a genetic vulnerability
or other type of vulnerability, that reduction
can be too much for them because those
brain cells are already maybe operating
at slightly reduced capacity or even maybe
moderately reduced capacity. And then when
you throw an infection on top of it just
pushes those cells over the edge and then
they begin to malfunction and that results
in what we call symptoms of mental illness.
It's not just Lyme disease though. So we've
got lots of research, decades of research
showing that inflammation, especially from
infections, can result in brain disorders,
mental disorders, neurological disorders,
we know this with certainty. So one study
looked at kids who developed an infection
that was serious enough to be hospitalized,
and they had like an 80-something percent
increased risk of developing a mental disorder,
most of them within the three months following
the hospitalization and the mental disorders were
across the board. These kids in the next three
months developed autism, schizophrenia, OCD,
learning disabilities, seizures, all sorts of
problems, which again, is consistent with this
more unifying model of how to think about mental
illness, these aren't discrete entities, but there
are obviously discrete symptoms and symptoms
matter. So to maybe follow up and just share if
you — well, I can stop there or I can share two —
Tim Ferriss: No, no, keep going.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: I'll share one or
two tidbits to highlight why mitochondria
are so important to this theory.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, please.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: So one, neurotransmitters,
everybody knows neurotransmitters play a role in
mental illness. Turns out mitochondria
play a critical role in the production,
the direct production, but also the release
and the regulation of major neurotransmitters,
including dopamine, serotonin, GABA, glutamate,
and others. So mitochondria actually are taking
food, broken down food, whether that's
carbohydrates, fast proteins, and they're
converting it into two different things primarily.
They're converting it into a fuel source, they're
burning it all the way down and then that fuel
gets used to create either ATP or heat. So it's
fuel or it's building blocks for other things.
It's building blocks to make new proteins or make
membranes or other things. And the mitochondria
are actually producing some of the primary
building blocks for those neurotransmitters.
But in fact, researchers have looked at cells
and if they take the mitochondria
out of the synapse, for instance,
but flood the synapse with ATP, so it's still
got lots of energy, it's got energy available,
the neurotransmitters actually don't get released.
The mitochondria are playing a direct role in
actually releasing the neurotransmitters.
And then I'll just share hormones too.
So everybody has heard about steroid
hormones, cortisol, estrogen, testosterone,
progesterone. Mitochondria actually control
the first step in the synthesis of all of
those hormones. And so if they are dysfunctional,
if there is a problem with mitochondria, you may
have a problem with producing those hormones.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Stars of the show, top of the
marquee, mitochondria. All right. I'm definitely
going to be doing more reading on mitochondria.
Now, let me ask a question or present a situation
in a question that I imagine is coming onto
the minds of many people listening, and that is,
"Tim Ferriss, if ketogenic diets are so amazing
and you feel so much better, why aren't you always
in ketosis?" And so I want to answer that and then
ask for your input. First, I will just lay out
for the sleep piece, what I've noticed to myself,
this is especially true with extended
fasting, is that some of whether the sleep,
let's just say six hours long, feels restful or
not often depends on my electrolyte consumption.
So if I am not consuming carbohydrates and I'm
just splitting off tons of water because I don't
have the retention capabilities, sometimes you at
least personally, I can develop lower back pain,
might be kidney related, and I think
it might be a cholinergic response,
I'm getting a little outside of my depth
here, but in terms of rapid heart rate,
trying to go to sleep, that seems to be largely
remedied by additional carbohydrate — excuse me,
seems to largely be remedied by additional
electrolyte, supplemental electrolyte intake.
However, the challenge for me is often one of not
dietary compliance. I happen to be a cholesterol
hyper absorber. So sometimes on the ketogenic
diet, I do see my lipid profiles go completely
cuckoo bananas and for many people, that's not the
case. But for me, I have witnessed that. So I have
some long-term considerations. I'm already taking
things like ezetimibe to control for some of the
risk factors, personally, I'm not recommending
that for anybody. Talk to your doctor.
But for people who have no familiarity with the
ketogenic diet and you're trying to help someone
sustain ketosis for a period of time, what
approach do you take? Do you use cream like
they did with children for a long time in
the studies looking at epilepsy? What is the
approach that you take to make it as easy
as possible for people to stick with it?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Well, and I think you
raise a really good point that not everybody
should be or needs to be on a ketogenic diet or
in ketosis long term, but for the patients that
I'm working with, they usually have serious
brain disorders that almost all of them are
disabled by their symptoms. And so like epilepsy,
where somebody's having multiple seizures every
single day, they have a very serious brain
disorder that needs immediate and consistent
medical intervention. And so if you're using
a ketogenic diet in those situations, most of
those patients do need it consistently. And it
in a way, I know people want a one-size-fits-all
answer. And I have to tell you, I have just
have to level with you, there isn't one.
With somebody who's really obese, say, weighs
340 pounds, I might use carb restriction alone.
So tell them to just eat less than 20 grams of
carbs a day. I don't really even have to get into
any limits on protein and I usually don't have to
recommend that they eat more fat or fat sources
because they have so much body fat to tap into.
And usually in those cases, we want to tap into
that body fat because they're usually interested
in losing some of it. And so in those people,
I'm going to recommend carb restriction and
that's about it. And usually, it's pretty easy
for them to maintain very high levels of ketones
and get the therapeutic brain effects as a result.
Once that same person loses enough of that
body fat, or if I have a different patient
coming to me who's already thin or athletic,
that person is going to need to probably
moderate the amount of protein they're
eating and consume more fat than they
really think they should be eating.
Tim Ferriss: We're both laughing,
because I know what that means. Yeah.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah. No. When I introduce
people to a ketogenic diet and I tell them how
much fat I want them eating, they're just like,
"You've got to be joking. There's no way that's
healthy. There's no way I can do that." But yeah,
so lots of ways to do it. I mean you can create
fat bombs, heavy whipping cream is really a great
tool. Some people drink it straight and just
they drink it like milk. You can actually put
a little bit of water in it to water it down
if you want it to be a little more like milk.
Tim Ferriss: It's also really good
in coffee, really good in coffee.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah, great in coffee.
It's great if you whip it and then it's whipped
cream, it's delicious. And you can use artificial
sweeteners if you want. I usually recommend
something like stevia or monkfruit. You can put
vanilla in it, you can put cocoa powder in it,
and then it's chocolate or vanilla and you can
freeze it and it becomes ice cream. I mean,
you can do a lot of things with it
to make it palatable and sustainable.
Tim Ferriss: So do you start
people off with directions,
let's just say they have lower percent body
fat, so they're not necessarily body builders,
but let's just say they're somewhere between a 20
percent body fat or less. And assuming that means
they're going to need to modify their intake to
increase the percentage of their dietary calories
from fat. Would you rather than say, change each
meal to have X, Y, and Z composition, say have
supplemental fat bombs, have some supplemental
heavy cream and that's how you'll basically
move the slider such that you're getting something
like 70 percent of your calories from fat. I'm not
sure if that's the target range, but you would
add the fat as opposed to change all the meals?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: I'm usually adding
the fat. So low carb is the baseline and then
the protein may need to vary. I want to
make sure they're getting adequate protein,
but it's not an all you can eat meat fest
necessarily. And so for most people, quite
honestly, it's usually a work in progress, because
everybody has different dietary preferences. Some
people like salads and if they like salads,
I'm going say, okay, have lots of salads, but
put some crumbled blue cheese on it, maybe some
almonds in there and avocado in there and douse
it with as much olive oil as you can tolerate and
whatever that is. Vinegar and oil, lot of oil,
that could become a very high fat thing. And
some people may love that, other people hate
it. And so other people are going to lean more
toward really fatty steaks or they want sweets,
in which case, we're going to be doing fat bombs
and whipped cream and ice cream and other things.
So there are lots of strategies, which is good
because that way we can figure out what does
this person and let's make it sustainable.
Tim Ferriss: I've one friend, it was in MD,
very, very competent MD who was in ketosis
for two years, two to three years straight.
And his general approach was skip breakfast. So
intermittent fast, maybe some coffee with heavy
cream and then have a large salad, lots of greens.
But in terms of actual net carbohydrates, pretty
low, with steak, cheese, tons of oil. And then
having of a moderate protein dinner, that would
be on the smaller side. And just so people know,
and please correct me if I'm getting this wrong,
but the reason a lot of folks have an aversion,
I think a lot of it is cultural conditioning to
attempt to do ketosis by simply going low carb and
they end up going very, very high protein. So they
think that they can do green salad with a mountain
of lean chicken breast and make it work, but the
body's really crafty. It happens to like ATP. So
the body will take the excess protein or a portion
of it and convert it in the liver, I think,
through a process called glucogenesis to glucose.
So then oops, you end up not being able to
sustain the higher levels of ketones because
your body just does not need them. If you have
high glucose levels, your body is getting what it
needs and your body's pretty smart about resource
allocation. Let's talk, definitely feel free,
if there's anything you'd like to add to that.
Any other common mistakes that you observe or
things that people don't think will affect ketosis
that tends to affect ketosis in unexpected ways?
Any common pitfalls you'd like to highlight?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Honestly, there are so
many and it's hard to put them into one category.
The nice thing about the ketogenic diet is that
there is an objective measure of whether you're
doing it right or not. And it's measure your
ketones. And if you're able to measure your blood
ketones, measure your blood ketones. And then do
the detective work to figure out why you're not
achieving the results you want and with a variety
of patients. So the detective work, which gets
to your exact question, what are the pitfalls?
I've seen people eating a lot of keto-labeled
junk food from the grocery store, Costco.
Tim Ferriss: Keto brownies all day long.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: "It's got keto on
the label, so it must be okay." And it's
filled with soluble corn fiber and sugar
alcohols and other stuff that clearly is
not necessarily natural and, lo and behold,
takes a lot of people out of ketosis and
prevents weight loss and prevents the brain
benefits and lots of other things that you want
to be achieving. So that's probably the single
biggest pitfall is all the keto-labeled junk food.
Tim Ferriss: If it seems too good to be true,
folks, probably is. I remember doing
keto way back in '97, '98, '99, and man,
the landscape was barren. I mean it was pork
rinds and heavy cream, and meat and eggs and water
and unsweetened ice tea. That was basically it.
But you can make it work. Let me ask you about a
note I have in front of me, which I would love to
hear you elaborate on and that is some psychiatric
medications impair metabolism, even though they
can reduce some of the symptoms of presumably
associated disorders in the short run. Could you
speak to that, maybe give examples because this is
certainly deeply interesting to me.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah. So let me at least
preface this discussion with kind of a caution up
front. So I'm going to say some things that may
get people really upset, and especially if you're
on these psychiatric medications. And I want to
just say for the record, it is really difficult
and dangerous to get off psychiatric medications,
especially if you've been on them for years or
decades. So please do not stop your medication
on your own. Please don't taper it on your own.
Work with your healthcare professional and do it
in a safe way. You're going to hear that I am
an advocate of sometimes trying to help people
get off medication. So I'm not trying to say you
must take your meds for the rest of your life,
but I'm just saying please don't do it in
a dangerous way because lots of people end
up in the hospital or suicidal or dead.
Tim Ferriss: No DIY folks, please. I know
people who've committed suicide after stopping
things cold turkey or attempting to taper but
not informing their doctors. So please be very
careful and only do any type of removal of meds
with professional supervision. Thank you.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: So with that said,
this is probably going to be the single
most controversial part of the theory
because ultimately what I'm saying is that mental
disorders are metabolic disorders of the brain.
And so that means metabolic impairment in
the body and/or brain can result in mental
symptoms. And yet we know many of our treatments
directly impair metabolism. So we know a lot
of antipsychotics, mood stabilizers,
even some antidepressants and others
cause people to gain weight, sometimes massive
amounts of weight. They can cause type 2 diabetes,
they can cause cardiovascular disease and all of
the risk factors for cardiovascular disease. So
they can cause hypertension, they can cause
abnormal lipids which we think contribute
to cardiovascular disease. And those are all
metabolic problems. That's not controversial
at all, their metabolic problems. These pills
are causing these metabolic problems. They are
right on the FDA package inserts of these meds. So
everything I just said is fact, non-controversial.
So the logical question from many people is,
"Well then, Chris, your theory must be wrong,
because these pills work. And
if they're impairing metabolism,
then that pretty much disproves your theory.
How would this make sense otherwise?"
And quite honestly, this was actually one
of the biggest things I struggled with in
developing this theory. I kind of was on this
path, metabolism mitochondria, wow, that seems to
be the connecting that's connecting a lot of dots.
And that was actually one of the obstacles for me,
was that exact question. How can I understand
that? And it's not that I want to deny that
the medications do reduce symptoms because they
do reduce symptoms. I've seen it work firsthand
as a psychiatrist. I've seen these medications
reduce symptoms and I'm not here to say all of
the clinical trials are a big lie and scam from
pharmaceutical companies. I don't think they are.
So I had to try to understand, well, then
what's going on? It kind of does disprove
my theory. So I've got to come up with an
explanation. And at the end of the day,
the explanation is this dichotomous reaction
of a cell to metabolic impairment. So when a
cell is metabolically compromised, there are some
other things that it can do. But the two for our
purposes right now are underactive or overactive
or hyperexcitable. And what we're really focused
on are hyperexcitable cells. So hyperexcitable
cells are producing experiences from your brain
networks, but they're producing these experiences
at the wrong time or the wrong intensity,
or they're not stopping when they should. That's
what hyperexcitability does. So a hyperexcitable
pain cell causes pain when you shouldn't have
pain. A hyperexcitable brain cell is producing
an experience sensation, cognition, something
that should not be happening when it happens.
And that could be anxiety,
depression, hallucinations, whatever.
In order to stop a hyperexcitable cell,
there are kind of two strategies you can use.
So one would be to slowly but surely restore the
metabolic health of that cell through strategies
that Tim, you've used yourself, exercise, ketones,
fasting, meditation, other things. Those are going
to restore metabolic health to those cells and
allow those cells to function normally again.
But the other way to stop a hyperexcitable cell is
to basically put a straitjacket on it, and to stop
it from functioning almost altogether. And that's
what a lot of the pills that we prescribe are
doing. They are impairing mitochondrial function
so that that cell has trouble firing at all.
And that means that symptoms of hyperexcitability
can stop. And so for some people, if you're having
a panic attack and somebody gives you a pill and
it makes that stop, that can feel really good.
If you're having a seizure, it can be life
saving. If you're psychotic and violent,
that can be lifesaving. So I'm not trying to
say these pills should never be used or they
don't have a time and a place because I think
they do. But if you take that pill long term,
that pill is like putting a straitjacket on
that cell, it's suppressing the function of
that cell over the long run. And what that means
is that that cell becomes weaker over the long run
and that may very well end up making
the illness even worse in the long run.
That is the theory. There are lots of people who
have been preaching that message for decades who
are going to say, "Dr. Chris Palmer, where the
hell have you been?" And then there are other
people who are going to say, "Chris Palmer,
how dare you say that? That is blasphemy and
you are now a dangerous quack." So I know I'm
going to get responses from all over the place,
but if you understand the science, if you
understand the basic science and all of
the evidence, that is a real possibility.
Tim Ferriss: Are there any, let's just say,
I don't want to say worst offenders, because
that has too much of a negative connotation,
but are there any particular drugs that stand
out to you as having a time and a place to
be used but then are particularly powerful at
disrupting metabolic integrity if they're used
chronically without any type of cycling off?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: The easy answer is,
and I could get into all of the science
documenting at the cellular level how and
why this has been supported, but we really
don't need that. The easy answer is just
look at the human being in front of you. If
they are gaining massive amounts of weight,
if they feel extraordinarily slowed down and now
they're sleeping 14 hours a day, 16 hours a day,
and they can barely function and their cognition
is trashed and they can't think anymore,
they can't read a book anymore, they
can't hold a job, they can't do school.
Those are all signs of metabolic
impairment of brain cells.
So those are the medications that I would be most
worried about, if somebody's taking — and it can
differ among people. If one person is taking a
medication and having all of those side effects
that I just listed, and yet another person is
taking maybe a lower dose of that same medication
and is finding it beneficial and still
able to function in life and still able
to do everything they want to do and not gaining
lots of weight and not becoming type 2 diabetic,
then all the power to that person and all the
power to that treatment. And I would be in full
support of that treatment. And I'm not at all here
to deny that treatments can work for some people.
But I didn't really say this, but
I would just want to say this,
in case people think, "Chris Palmer is way
too pessimistic, who the hell is this guy?"
The real answer is that mental disorders are now
the leading cause of disability on our planet.
And it's not because people aren't getting
treatment. A lot of those people are getting
treatment, and it's because our current treatments
fail to work for them. That is a fact, and that is
why I am so passionate about this work, because
I want to help those people who are being told,
"There's nothing more we have to offer you.
There's nothing more we can do. Just take your
pills and stop complaining." I want to help them.
Tim Ferriss: If we wanted to take a moment to act
as patient advocates. So many patients, many
people who are taking psychiatric medications
or medications for psychiatric conditions will
not have doctors who are familiar with the many
functions and purposes of mitochondria, how
the ketogenic diet and ketones interplay with
energetic production and can alleviate, say,
inflammation. I mean, for those people who
don't know, you can find lots of literature
to support this. Many types of ketones,
including I think beta hydroxybutyrate
is probably one of the most obvious to
search for, are highly anti-inflammatory.
I mean, another observation I had when deep
into ketosis is that many of my chronic pains
decreased significantly, including tendinosis
and other issues. So for people who don't have
a doctor who's well-versed in these things,
but let's assume for the moment that their
doctor is open minded to continued education,
are there any resources that you would suggest? I
mean I would imagine that your book is certainly
one of them. So the book being Brain Energy.
Are there other resources you might suggest
that a patient ask their doctor
if they're willing to read up on
so that they can have these conversations?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Absolutely. So you
can go to my website, chrispalmermd.com, or you
can go to a website that is about to launch,
brainenergy.com, and I will be posting free
resources, studies, lay articles. So already
on my website, I've got lay press articles if you
just want to better understand these treatments
and the science behind them. But I've also got
links to the medical peer-reviewed literature.
And that's important if you're trying to get your
healthcare practitioner to take this seriously and
at least have a discussion with you about using
this as a treatment option. Even if you can't
understand what that article is saying, because
it's written in medical language, you can print
it out and give it to your healthcare provider and
that will build some credibility. So don't go and
just say, "Oh, I saw this YouTube video on the
internet and it was great and I think you should
do this." If you arm yourself with some of this
scientific literature, you're more likely to get
a good response from your healthcare practitioner
to at least work with you or consider it with you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, mention Harvard when you
mention Dr. Christopher Palmer and not YouTube.
Mention Harvard before you mention YouTube.
Pro tip. So the next question I'd love to ask,
well, actually I'll make an observation, which
is not necessarily an accurate observation,
but as I'm thinking about your description of
some of these common medications that can disrupt
metabolic function, sometimes to good
short-term clinical effect, as you mentioned,
right? If somebody is psychotic and at
risk of injuring or killing themselves,
these medications have a role and if
someone is currently on these medications,
let's say they recognize some of
the symptoms, weight gain, lethargy,
sacrificed cognition, they don't necessarily,
this is not medical advice, but just a hypothesis,
need to rush to get off of these medications. It
seems to me they could also potentially consider
adding dietary interventions, exercise, et
cetera, that could act as a counterbalance
so that they are facilitating some
cellular rejuvenation or metabolic
efficiency while they're continuing to use these
medications. So it's not all or nothing, it's not
remove all of these components and then
add all these components. They can be
parallel tracks. Is that fair to say?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: It is essential
to say. So when I have patients come to me who
say, "I want to try this ketogenic diet thing,"
they stay on all their current meds. Taking people
off their meds is dangerous, please hear that. And
the way that I think about it is it means that
those cells are now almost shriveled up. Those
cells are struggling because they have been
suppressed for so long and we need, so when
you take those meds away, they're going to become
excitable immediately. As energy rushes into those
cells, they're going to become hyperexcitable. And
it's like picking a cast off of a broken leg and
then saying, "Go run." It's not a good idea.
So the first step is exactly what you said,
maybe implement some other
strategies, dietary change,
ketogenic diet, or otherwise. Sometimes it's just
let's remove all the junk food and the sugar and
some other stuff that's inflammatory and that
might be enough of a first step for some people.
But add some exercise, try to get your sleep
under control, and then if that is working,
and especially if it's working in a profound
way, then maybe slowly but surely over time,
see if you can slowly but surely taper your meds.
Tim Ferriss: For people who may be in my position,
which is huge fan, convert, true believer in
certainly the psychoemotional, and I suppose
we're looking a little under the hood, energetic
benefits of the ketogenic diet, but concerned
about some of the long term cardiac effects due to
my cholesterol, hyper absorption, or I should say
sterols really because desmosterol and all these
other plant sterols are also absorbed, which can
cause issues. What is your current position on
use of exogenous ketones or ketone supplements
as a way to perhaps partially achieve some of what
you've seen with the dietary interventions? Is it
possible? Is it contraindicated? I always have
a divided position on this because I look at,
and this may be an unfair comparison, but I look
at say, keto acidosis and I think to myself,
it really doesn't make sense to me from an
evolutionary perspective that it would be
good for you to have normal or elevated glucose
levels while simultaneously pushing ketones to
two or three millimolars with exogenous keto
consumption. It doesn't, at least at face value,
seem like that would be without risk.
How would you suggest I think about this?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: The real answer
is I don't think anybody knows for sure.
A lot of people are really interested in exogenous
ketones and obviously it's so much easier to drink
ketones than do a ketogenic diet. So no question
about that. The first, just fact I want to just
share, or the first observation I want to share is
that there are tens of thousands of children with
treatment resistant epilepsy who are using
ketogenic diets to control their epilepsy.
Exogenous ketones have been around for years.
We do not yet have even one case report
of one child being able to transition
off a ketogenic diet to exogenous
ketones and maintain the benefits of seizure
improvement or seizure freedom. Trust me,
thousands of parents and neurologists and
others have almost certainly tried it.
Do I have documentation of that? No, because
they're not reporting it because it didn't
work out. So there's no way to really —
Tim Ferriss: It'd be a hell of a lot
easier for everybody involved. So you
have to assume they would've tried it.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: I have to assume that some
of these patients with epilepsy gave it a shot.
I know with certainty, I've talked with patients
with bipolar disorder and other disorders,
for instance, who were using a ketogenic diet to
control their symptoms, they did try exogenous
ketones, went off the diet and symptoms came
back sometimes with a vengeance. And I've used
it in clinical practice as well with patients and
I have not seen a significant benefit of exogenous
ketones. So those observations make me think
a couple of things. One is that the ketogenic
diet is doing a lot, it's improving insulin
signaling, it's changing the gut microbiome,
improving hormones, all sorts of things. But when
you force your liver to make ketones, because
that's where most of the ketones in the human
body are made. And interestingly, they're made by
mitochondria. So it is actually the mitochondria
in the liver that are making the ketones.
Tim Ferriss: "Help me help you, mitochondria."
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Well, so one of the things
that's happening when somebody's on a ketogenic
diet is actually you're getting this thing called
mitochondrial biogenesis in the liver, which means
that your liver cells are actually making more
mitochondria to meet this demand. That in and of
itself might be improving the health of your liver
and the ability of your liver to send kind
of healthier metabolic signals to your brain
and throughout your body. The liver plays a
profound role in terms of metabolic health.
We know that, and there are lots of
signals. It gets really complicated
really quickly. But the bottom line
is increasing mitochondria in cells
confers health benefits pretty much across the
board, as long as they're healthy mitochondria.
If you increase defective ones, that's not
going to do very do much. So I actually, sadly,
think exogenous ketones are not going to be the
magic answer. Could they play a role for some
people? Probably. They might be good like on an
as-needed basis or they might be a good rescue for
somebody who's using a ketogenic diet, falls off
the wagon, gets really sick, needs a quick rescue.
Maybe exogenous ketones would help that
person in that situation. I don't know.
Tim Ferriss: From a first-person
subjective experience, I can say,
having consumed a lot of exogenous ketones
of many, many different types, that for
certain types of physical performance, for
physical performance at altitude in any
hypoxic state, the supplemental ketones
can be very helpful. And that applies,
in my case, to intermittent fasting also. So
if I'm intermittent fasting and, let's say,
I have podcast to record in the morning but I
haven't eaten in 12 hours, whatever it might be,
supplemental ketones plus some caffeine does a
lot of heavy lifting for a short period of time.
But I have not experienced the mood, the extended
durable mood-elevating effects or cognitive
benefits from exogenous ketones that I have
from the ketogenic diet. There's no comparison,
in my experience. I do find and also I'll
sound like a broken record, not medical advice,
fasting, it's a shame that you just can't get
extended fasting studies in humans through
IRB these days. I really wish that were different.
But don't just DIY long-term fast, folks.
But for me personally, when I am segueing into
say a three-day fast, which would be my most
typical duration of fast, I have done up to 10
days but more typically I'll do three days. I
will use exogenous ketones on my first day of
full fasting, which is typically 12 to 18 hours
after beginning of fast, after an early dinner
to allow me to eke out one more productive day of
work on a Friday. The use of exogenous ketones as
a booster shot or an accelerant that assists with
the segue into ketosis, I do find quite helpful.
But I do not find it, in any way, to replicate
the psychological or energetic benefits of the
ketogenic diet. Sadly, it would be a lot easier.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: It would. No. And I
think that's so helpful but it certainly lines
up with what I've seen in other people too.
Tim Ferriss: Now if you had to specifically,
and I know we've been going for a while so
maybe we'll do a round two sometime, but
a quick note because I thought from a historical
perspective, this was fun to see at least.
So we were talking about
ketogenic diet and epilepsy.
Now, not using the term ketogenic
diet, no doubt, but this knowledge,
this observation goes all the way back to
Hippocrates that fasting can stop seizures.
I always get a dumb smile plastered on my face
when I see that. What is old is once new again,
in a sense. And look. I mean people had humors and
spirits and all sorts of things that at least as
it stands right now, we believe to be false.
But doesn't mean they got everything wrong.
So I do find that fasting maybe in the same
bucket. Cold baths for depression, which were
prescribed for a long time. I think there may be
something to that as well. You can do that and
get some norepinephrine in the system or you could
use a selective norepinephrine reuptake inhibitor.
But really is it that different? I'm not sure.
That is a digression. I just had to mention that
because I love the historical note. In the case of
schizophrenia, specifically, because this can be
such a challenging diagnosis/condition with the
recognition that one person next to the other,
both with the same diagnosis, could present
very differently. Do you have any additional
color to add theories for why this type of
metabolic intervention, the ketogenic diet,
seems to help specifically with schizophrenia?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah. So this goes back
again, to, in many ways, this is nothing
new, folks, although this may sound new
and groundbreaking. So in the 1940s, some
of the first biological studies of people
with mental illness included actually drawing
blood from the veins of people with bipolar
disorder and schizophrenia. At that time,
they were usually labeled the same thing.
They were usually just called schizophrenic.
Tim Ferriss: Oh man. I would've
been schizophrenic also.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Same.
Tim Ferriss: Man. Another two for one.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Probably. Sadly.
Tim Ferriss: Be careful when you're
born, folks. Be careful when you're born.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Exactly. They would draw
blood from their veins and they noticed that
people with these diagnoses had higher levels of
lactate in their blood than people who did not
have a psychiatric diagnosis and that if they
exercised them, the spike in lactate was even
more pronounced. So this difference in lactate
production has been observed for 80 years now.
And for those of you who don't know, this is
a metabolic marker of stress, either hypoxia,
which directly stresses mitochondria because
mitochondria are the only thing in the cell that's
using oxygen, or it's a direct kind of indication
of mitochondrial impairment, that the mitochondria
can't keep up with the energy demands.
And so the cell starts using glycolysis
as kind of a backup fuel source and spills out
lactate into the bloodstream as a consequence.
Now, that's actually, probably, a really good
thing because the lactate actually can be
used as a fuel source from other cells. And so
this lactate is a signal of metabolic stress,
but it's an adaptive response. So the increased
lactate, we don't want to just get rid of it
and not address the metabolic problem.
But then all of the neuroimaging studies
beginning in the 1990s, in particular when
we had functional neuroimaging studies,
the PET scans, all of the lines of evidence were
converging on mitochondria and oxidative stress
or glucose hypometabolism or other things. So
by about 2000, that was the year that the first
group of researchers proposed the
mitochondrial theory of bipolar disorder.
By 2004, numerous other researchers were jumping
on the bandwagon of the mitochondrial theory of
bipolar disorder. Within a couple of years, that
quickly segued also to include schizophrenia.
And within a few more years, that quickly also
included major depressive disorder. So depression,
bipolar, and schizophrenia have all had enormous
support from numerous lines of evidence.
This goes to genetic. What do these genetic
things do? Like people who have these genetic
predispositions to bipolar disorder,
what are those genes actually causing?
They're causing metabolic impairment in the
cells. That's what they're causing. They're
causing dysfunction at the synapse, which
almost always includes mitochondria because
mitochondria are hyperpopulated at synapses.
And so, in many ways, the mitochondrial theory
of schizophrenia, bipolar disorder, depression
is actually nothing new. And I know those
researchers, if this theory takes off, those
researchers are going to be pissed. "F Chris
Palmer! We came up with this theory. This is our
theory. This is not his theory." In many ways,
I fully respect and acknowledge and am filled
with gratitude to all of those people. I just
climbed up on their shoulders and just added
to what they've been doing. It's not like I'm
creating this new fanatical theory of
what causes mental illness. I'm simply
putting all of the foundation together and
climbing up on other people's shoulders.
Tim Ferriss: I'm so glad to be having this
conversation I suppose, not to be too Tim-centric,
but in part because the descriptions, the
theories, the underlying physiology and
how all these things tie together with respect
to the presentation of "psychiatric disorders"
map perfectly to my personal experience. And
just because Tim considers himself an N-of-1
doesn't prove scientific truth.
However, it makes a lot of sense.
There's no aspect of this that, to me, seems
out of left field and a non sequitur from the
understanding of basic cellular metabolism. It
just makes sense to me. Sure. If you have 20
children in a preschool class and you don't
feed any of them lunch, three hours later,
you're going to have 30 grumpy kids and each
grumpy kid is going to have a different behavior.
Maybe one's throwing blocks. Maybe one's crying in
the corner. But the underlying cause is actually
fairly straightforward and it is a fundamental
underlying cause that can explain all of these
different emergent behaviors rather than trying
to treat the block-throwing and the crying all
separately with a different combination of drugs.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: That is a perfect analogy
because right now, the mental health field says,
"This child has block-throwing disorder." "This
child has grumpy disorder." "This child has
handwriting disorder," and "This child has
defiant disorder. He spoke back to me in a really
poor manner." We label those different things and
then we assume they are different disorders.
They're certainly different behaviors and they
might require different interventions. One child
might need discipline and another maybe not,
but you can solve all of it by feeding them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Perfect.
Tim Ferriss: I'm very excited by
not just the presentation of these ideas but
hopefully, the conversation and the debate that
this will produce. I'm always so happy to have
conversations like this on the podcast because I
hate to say it, folks, but you need to be your
own advocate. You have to be your own health
advocate and you cannot expect other people to
do it for you. Even the best intentioned and
most competent of doctors, the way things are
currently structured in our healthcare system,
they may simply not have the
available bandwidth and time,
depending on where and how they operate, to do
the requisite research or quarterback some of the
exploration of these metabolic interventions.
And so, you really need to take ownership,
radical ownership, of your own advocacy. This
podcast, your book, the resources that you'll have
on your website are some simple ways to do that.
And fortunately, also the mechanisms. If you take
an afternoon to try to educate yourself, they are
reasonably, easily understood. I mean this is not
quantum physics we're talking about, which is
not to minimize it in any sense. But you can
gain a basic understanding, as a layperson, of the
building blocks that you are dealing with. And I
should say, also because this is important, that
brain energy is not solely focused. I know we've
dedicated a lot of time to the ketogenic diet,
but it explores many other levers and factors
so not just diet and not just the ketogenic
diet within diet but exercise, relationships,
removing metabolic toxins. There are other levers
that you can pull with the objective of this type
of metabolic reboot or metabolic rejuvenation.
I suppose I would ask just a few questions
in closing and one is knowing what you do of
exercise, having looked at that as a variable,
are there any particular forms of
exercise that seem to demonstrate
effectiveness for mitochondrial health
or addressing some of the conditions that
you're used to seeing as a clinician?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: At this point,
we don't have great evidence across the board for
exactly which one. So there's one large study,
over a million Americans, that looked at exercise
as a prevention tool for mental illness or poor
mental health. And what they found was that group
sports, cycling, gym activities were best and I
think the theme is cardio and pairing exercise
with relationships, pairing exercise with social
contact. And so you're getting a two-fer with that
one. You're getting some bonding and friendships
and other things. So I would say those are great.
The research on exercise as a treatment for mental
illness is actually very — it's a mixed
bag and some meta analyses have actually
found that exercise does not appear to be
an effective treatment for mental illness
and I talk about some of the confounding
variables in that. One of the biggest ones
is that a lot of medications that
impair mitochondrial function,
which include a lot of psychiatric medications but
also include diabetes medications and some others,
if you're taking medications that
impair mitochondrial function,
those people do not get the same benefits from
exercise as people not taking those medications.
And we have decent studies, randomized
controlled trials of older adults
exercising. Half of them get
metformin. Half of them don't.
The ones who did not get metformin had
more mitochondrial benefits and adaptations
than the ones who got metformin.
Tim Ferriss: Oh. That's interesting.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: And we know that metformin
appears to impair mitochondrial function,
at least in some people, in many ways. But
again, when it comes to psychiatric patients,
antipsychotics and others are even more powerful.
So with that said, I think the one thing I would
say is zone 2 training. So let me
just go to a zone 2 training. And
we know that if you improve mitochondria quantity,
quality, that even if you're just doing it in the
muscle cells, that translates to brain benefits
and that you actually get more mitochondria and
you actually get more neuroplasticity in the brain
as a consequence of improving your muscle size.
And probably, zone 2 training is the be-all,
end-all. If you have enough time to do a lot of
different types of exercise, I would absolutely
say mix it up. Do some cardio, zone 2 training,
maybe include some high intensity but also do some
isometrics. Try to grow your muscles as large as
you can or as large as you want and sure, do
some stretching and stress reduction, yoga,
other things. Those can be helpful too. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Zone 2 training,
folks. Get after it. And I will say also,
there is a book. It is somewhat outdated,
but for people who are interested in some of the
growth factor adaptations related to exercise like
release of brain drive, neurotrophic factor, and
things like that, there is a book. It is older
so I don't recommend it unreservedly because I
think that there have been recent discoveries
that would probably modify it but called Spark:
The Revolutionary New Science of Exercise and the
Brain. This is from 2013. So I think that it's
worth reading at least a Wikipedia entry on.
But zone 2 training, and I will also just add
to that. For people who may or may not recognize
the word metformin, I just want to underscore
something. Again, feel free to interject. There's
no biological free lunch, guys. If you take a drug
that has a high amplitude of effect in X, chances
are that's not completely isolated within this
complex, closed system known as the human body. So
there are people who have used metformin for life
extension purposes and I have long been, this is
based on conversations with scientists who focus
on metformin, skeptical of the upside benefit
of using metformin if you are in reasonably
good metabolic shape. This example you gave
just goes to show it is not just naive but it is
sometimes dangerous, certainly not without risk,
to take drugs like this. And for people who have
no context, I believe metformin is predominantly
used as a medication in type 2 diabetes. Is that —
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Absolutely.
Yes. Type 2 diabetes.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's probably off-patent
now and generics are everywhere. I don't know.
But I think it was a glucophage or glucophage.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: I never know how to say
that. Atrophy macrophage, I guess. Glucophage. Is
that right? Am I getting that pronunciation right?
I always screw it up. One of the two. Anyway.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You guys get the idea. But if
you're repurposing drugs, which many people are,
and you've got to be careful and some of
them are very interesting like rapamycin,
which is an immunosuppressant. That's not
a joke. It does exhibit some life extension
in various species and animal models. But you've
got to be careful before you introduce sort of a
red hot variable like that. You've got to
do lots and lots of homework. So anyway,
that's a good cautionary note as well.
So I think — is there anything you'd
like to add to that before we begin to wind?
Dr. Christopher Palmer: I think the only thing
I'd like to add to the last thing you said is
that if you've got type 2 diabetes and you're
on metformin, there's almost no doubt metformin
is the best drug for you to probably be taking —
Tim Ferriss: Agreed. Great point. Great point.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: — if you need a drug.
However, I would also encourage you, if you've got
type 2 diabetes, type 2 diabetes can be reversed.
You can use dietary strategies, especially
low-carb or ketogenic dietary strategies,
to reverse your diabetes, get off medication,
and dramatically improve your health.
I have seen it time and again. Actually, I've
got this. Yeah. I did it with my father and it
was nothing short of miraculous for him. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'll just add another side note,
which is probably going to get me in
trouble, so I'm going to say it again,
folks. I'm not a doctor. I don't play one on
the internet. However, one of the reasons I
wish it were easier to study extended fasting
in humans, which way back in the day you could.
I mean there were some astonishing studies
with extended fasting and then that changed.
But I have multiple anecdotes. I recognize the
plural of anecdote does not equal randomized,
controlled trial. However, I have numerous
anecdotes of people I have direct contact with,
probably five or six now, who have seemingly
regenerated their pancreas' ability through,
I guess what, the beta islid cells to produce
insulin as long-term type 1 diabetics using
one month of fasting per month, so for
five to six months. They do the first
week of the month fasting for five to six
months. And in multiple cases, it appears
to be the case that some people regain the ability
to produce at least small quantities of insulin.
And that, I think, is thought to be probably
entirely implausible by most folks out there.
But this is why I'm so excited to be engaged
with the science. My foundation supports so
much science because we just don't know. There
are so many open questions. And in the meantime,
that gives me all the more excitement about
books like yours, Brain Energy: A Revolutionary
Breakthrough in Understanding Mental Health—and
Improving Treatment for Anxiety, Depression,
OCD, PTSD, and More, because you are discussing
interventions that have, in the vast majority of
people, very limited downside risk and that are
compatible with many other therapies. They don't
need to be a monotherapy. It's not either/or. Is
that fair to say? I mean it seems fair to say and
that's part of why I'm so enthusiastic about this.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Yeah. Absolutely. I think
that we definitely have a mental health
crisis in the world today. I mean records,
sky-high record numbers of people suffering
from depression, anxiety, burnout,
et cetera. And there's no question that a
lot of the strategies that I've discussed
in the book will address those easy cases.
I think the much more shocking and revolutionary
thing is that I'm also talking about things like
bipolar disorder, which again, you are a perfect
testament to so many people that if you have
bipolar disorder, you do not have to be disabled
for life from it. You do not have to take pills
that are going to make you overweight or obese,
type 2 diabetic, impaired cognitively. You can
find other strategies to address bipolar disorder.
You are simply a model person who figured it out
on your own or talked to great, smart people who
gave you hints along the way or whatever. I
don't know how the hell you figured it all out,
but you are a shining example for
lots of people. And what I want to
say is for all of you who know somebody with
schizophrenia or bipolar disorder who are
not like Tim Ferriss, there is a better way.
Tim Ferriss: I really appreciate you saying
that. I have had a lot of help along the way
and as I've had help, I've tried to showcase
the people who have helped me on this podcast. I
think your work is going to help so many people.
It took me a long fucking time to grope through
the darkness to find certain tools and what
made me so resolute in my desire to have you on
the podcast is I listened to you and I looked
at the case studies and I listened to the case
studies and I looked at the interventions and I
said for fuck sake. Pardon my French. But you
have assembled many of the tools that took me
decades to stumble into, eventually, and then
assemble into some type of portfolio for myself.
For God's sake, if I can save people a whole
bunch of time and angst and maybe help them
reduce the frequency or intensity or duration of
their episodic experiences, of these conditions,
then I'm all for it and the easiest way I can do
that is to have somebody like you on the podcast.
So Chris, I really appreciate you taking the time
and people can find you on Twitter and Instagram
at Chris Palmer MD, all things Chris Palmer,
and Chris Palmer. That's my phrasing, not yours.
ChrisPalmerMD.com. The book again is Brain Energy:
A Revolutionary Breakthrough in Understanding
Mental Health—and Improving Treatment for
Anxiety, Depression, OCD, PTSD, and More.
I would emphasize the "and More" because as
we've mentioned multiple times, really — I'm
going to really make the most of this preschool
example. Just because the kids are all behaving
differently, if they didn't eat in three hours,
it is entirely possible that there is a shared
underlying cause. So why not attempt to address
that? Especially when the downside risk is minimal
and the approaches, the implementation is known.
There are many ways to approach these things. So
Chris, thank you again. I really appreciate you
taking the time and I am very optimistic that your
work and this book will help many, many people.
Dr. Christopher Palmer: Thank you Tim. Thanks
for everything you've been doing
and you continue to do. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you. And for everybody
listening, the link to everything in the
show notes. So all the names, various studies, et
cetera, the book, of course, and everything else,
we'll link to as usual in the show notes
at tim.blog/podcast. And until next time,
be just a little kinder than necessary and
that includes being kinder to yourself. If
your compassion does not include yourself,
it is incomplete. Thank you for tuning in.